EASTERN TIME.
WATCH AND LISTEN TO THAT ON THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
>> ♪ ♪
>> WHETHER I AM NOT IS PRESIDENT
TO SHUT THIS PRESIDENT UP RIGHT
NOW.
HE IS UNDERMINING THE DOCTORS
AND THE SCIENTISTS WHO ARE
TRYING TO HELP THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
IT’S UNACCEPTABLE FOR HIM TO BE
BLABBERING WITH UNFACTUAL
INFORMATION.
>> TAKE CARE OF THOSE WHO ARE
EXPOSED TO THE VIRUS.
THAT MEANS WE HAVE TO DO
TESTING.
WE HAVE TO GET THE TESTING KITS
UP AND READY.
>> Ed: JOE BIDEN AND BERNIE
SANDERS WENT ONE-ON-ONE IN THE
LATEST DEMOCRATIC DEBATE.
IT MOVED TO WASHINGTON HELD
WITHOUT AN AUDIENCE DUE TO THE
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK.
BOTH HAMMERING THE PRESIDENT ON
THE HANDLING OF THIS VIRUS.
PRIMARIES ARE SET TO TAKE PLACE
TOMORROW.
ELSON IS IN OHIO.
GOOD MORNING.
>> JOE BIDEN AND BERNIE SANDERS
ARE ON THE SAME PAGE WHEN IT
COMES TO THEIR CRITICISM OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HOW HE HAS
HANDLED THIS CRISIS.
THEY OFFERED DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS
WITH DEALING WITH IT.
JOE BIDEN WOULD MOBILIZE THE
U.S. MILITARY RIGHT NOW BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THE CAPACITY TO BUILD
500 BED HOSPITALS TO HELP WITH
SHORTAGES.
SANDERS WOULD USE THE NATIONAL
GUARD AS THEY ARE DOING IN NEW
YORK.
>> THIS IS LIKE A WAR.
WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
EVERYTHING YOU NEED IN TERMS OF
DEALING WITH THIS CRISIS WOULD
BE FREE.
>> THIS CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC
EXPOSES THE INCREDIBLE WEAKNESS
AND DYSFUNCTIONALITY OF OUR
CURRENT HEALTHCARE SYSTEM.
>> WITH DUE RESPECT TO MEDICARE
FOR ALL.
YOU HAVE A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM
IN ITALY.
IT DID NOT WORK THERE.
>> PRIMARIES TOMORROW.
GEORGIA AND LOUISIANA ARE
POSTPONING THEIR ELECTIONS.
FOUR STATES VOTING TOMORROW WILL
PROCEED AS PLAN.
THE OHIO SECRETARY OF STATE
DOESN’T SEE OHIO REVERSING
COURSE AND THAT THE POLLS WILL
OPEN TOMORROW, TUESDAY AT 6:30
A.M.
ELECTION OFFICIALS SAY EVERY
OHIO POLLING LOCATION WILL HAVE
SUPPLIES TO FOLLOW GUIDELINES.
WE ARE TOLD PENS AND VOTING
MACHINES WILL BE CLEANED AFTER
EVERY USE.
AS RESTAURANTS SHUTDOWN SOME
BELIEVE VOTINGS POLLS SHOULD
SHUTDOWN AS WELL.
>> CAN GUARANTEE NO VOTER WILL
GET SICK?
>> THERE ARE NO 100%.
THEIR POLLING LOCATION THE
PEOPLE THAT WORK IT ARE WELL
TRAINED.
THEY HAVE THE SUPPLIES TO WIPE
DOWN THAT LOCATION AND THE RIGHT
INSTRUCTIONS.
AS LONG AS THEY FOLLOW THEM FOR
US.
IF THE VOTERS FOLLOW PROPER
HYGIENE IT WILL BE SAFE AND
HEALTHY.
>> THERE ARE SOME MAIL IN VOTING
OPTIONS AND CURBSIDE VOTING
OPTIONS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS STATE’S LONG